a pocos kilómetros de la capital
económica sao paulo el pequeño municipio
de aluminio acaba de vivir una tragedia
que conmocionó a todo el país
el hijo de glaus ya y fusión libera
tenía tres años
esto fue por su segundo cumpleaños de
este pequeño que ya sufría de
insuficiencia respiratoria no resistió
más de 24 horas al coronavirus buscaron
buscaron camas en urgencias en todo el
estado y no había ninguna porque
necesitaba una cama en cuidados
intensivos especializados en hobbies
y como ya tenía una insuficiencia
hasta las 3 y 30 de la mañana no aguanto
la enfermedad
al igual que su hijo 4000 enfermos
graves siguen esperando una cama en
cuidados intensivos
desmantelaron los hospitales de campaña
demasiado rápido y ahora necesitamos
camas y dónde están esos hospitales de
campaña la situación
estamos en una situación muy crítica y
estamos desesperados
brasil está al borde del colapso
sao paulo y otras 25 grandes ciudades
del país declararon el estado de
emergencia sanitaria en la unidad de
cuidados intensivos de este hospital
universitario desde hace varios días no
hay camas disponibles este paciente
acaba de recuperarse es un rayo de
esperanza muy débil para estos médicos
que ven aquí cada día los estragos de la
nueva variante brasileña más contagiosa
estamos muy contentos de ver pacientes
como el señor que acaban de ver que ya
no necesita asistencia respiratoria y se
está recuperando pero al mismo tiempo
vemos cada vez más pacientes jóvenes que
necesitan asistencia mecánica como este
paciente que llegó hace 3 días
aunque no tenía antecedentes médicos ni
ninguna otra patología hacía deporte si
la gente está cansada de la pandemia sí
claro que estamos cansados pero el virus
no lo está está aquí y tenemos esta
variante brasileña mucho más contagiosa
nos falta de todo nos estamos quedando
sin profesionales de la salud está claro
que no tenemos un plan nacional ni
siquiera a nivel regional no nos estamos
adelantando a la pandemia solo estamos
respondiendo a ella en caso de
emergencia en brasil debido a la falta
de medidas nacionales de aislamiento
adoptadas desde el inicio de la pandemia
son los estados los que deciden por sí
mismos sin embargo aunque sao paulo ha
impuesto severas restricciones en las
últimas semanas en río las playas y los
restaurantes sólo hasta ahora están
cerrando la aparente despreocupación de
los cariocas es especialmente
preocupante en las favelas estos barrios
obreros donde los residentes no tienen
más remedio que salir a trabajar en el
complexo da maré esta asociación trata
de apoyar lo mejor que puede a las
familias contagiadas que ya no recibe la
ayuda de emergencia del gobierno que fue
cancelada recientemente y debe volver a
ser votada a principios de abril
la idea es que no tengan que salir a la
calle porque cuando una persona se
contagia normalmente toda la familia se
contagia también y tienen que permanecer
aislados en cuarentena para no propagar
más el virus
comida muy preciada para gracias
buenos días gracias se contagia de kobe
19 el 26 del mes pasado mientras estaba
en el trabajo empecé a sentir síntomas
así que fui a ver a un médico unos días
después me hice la prueba que fue
positiva y me despidieron del trabajo de
la noche a la mañana enferma sin
subsidio de desempleo ni ayudas del
gobierno sin su ayuda no podría haber
sobrevivido eso es esencial para mí
porque no tengo ingresos en este hangar
se hacen pruebas de kobe gratuitas a
aquellos que lo quieran va a ser un poco
desagradable vale bájese la mascarilla
hacerse la prueba en una farmacia creo
que cuesta unos 23 dólares yo no los
tengo y mucha gente está en mi misma
situación
buenos días chicas cómo están el número
de voluntarios es insuficiente para la
coordinadora del proyecto luna arauca
siente que está aumentando que hay más
casos
y lo que estamos viendo aquí a
diferencia de esta señora que se está
cuidando es que cada vez viene menos
gente a hacerse las pruebas hemos visto
un descenso en el número de pruebas el
mes pasado hicimos 1.700 pruebas
y este mes sólo 700 así que estamos
viendo un descenso importante en el
número de pruebas y al mismo tiempo un
aumento en el número de muertes este mes
hemos registrado 15 muertos por su lona
virus mientras que antes no llegábamos a
4 o 5 muertes al mes
criticado por su reticencia a la
vacunación y su gestión de la crisis el
presidente ya y el bolsonaro acaba de
nombrar a marcelo quiroga como ministro
de salud el cuarto desde el inicio de la
pandemia las primeras vacunas producidas
en brasil se distribuirán en los
próximos días el gobierno prometió más
de 220 millones de dosis para septiembre
de 2021 un futuro demasiado lejano para
los médicos cuando cada minuto mueren
dos brasileños por kobe en brasil